nobody's talking about is how women have  been equally psychologically able to  short men for centuries  and if you don't believe as an  experiment right now pull out your phone  download any dating app pretend to be a  short guy strap the [ __ ] in  you women are ruthless  every profile same thing hey if you're  under six feet just swipe left I don't  want to talk to you that's gross uh  you're not even real people  you remind me my little brother it's  adorable don't waste my time I'm not  gonna waste yours  and I got news for you ladies at some  point you're going to have to settle  not everybody except kids are going to  play in the NBA  I played trombone for four years you  know what that means I have a very  strong tongue plus I'm low to the ground  I'm more likely to go down on you that's  just basic physics